There's a really strange story about how Donald
Trump will just not stop talking about North
Korean dictator.
Kim Jong [inaudible] to other world leaders
and the other world's leaders are getting
really weirded out by what tunneled Trump
is doing.
You know how sometimes a four year old will
be obsessed with telling the same story over
and over again to anyone they talk to.
My Blue Lego's disappeared and I made a green
castle and Mommy gave me a cookie.
Oh, that's great.
That's great.
Yeah, and just telling the same story over
and over again.
Trump has become the sort of adult, I'm not
going to call it the adult version of that,
but sort of the adult version of that.
Trump reportedly going into the same weird
monologue about how wonderful dictator Kim
Jong Un is to any world leader that will listen.
And we had the g seven last month.
We're according to three sources.
There was a meeting with the world leaders,
uh, understandably as there were of course,
many meetings.
And the topic of North Korea actually came
up during this meeting and the context was,
hey, North Korea has been firing short range
ballistic missiles into the Sea of Japan.
And Trump interjects this tangential, wacky
story about just how Great Kim John Moon is
and how great Trump's relationship with Kim
Jong UN is.
He rambled for 10 minutes reportedly, and
the room of world leaders was invisibly stunned
silence according to three people that were
in the room.
Funny how often that happens because yesterday
we learned that at the g seven Trump walked
into a meeting set to be with the Egyptian
president and yelled, where's my favorite
dictator?
Also putting the room into this stunned silence.
And here it is this time, uh, talking just
so positively about another dictator, Kim
Jong.
And now here's where it gets even weirder.
Donald Trump has told this exact same story
of, or verbatim before in Canada last year,
Trump told this exact same story to the same
group of world leaders minus Boris Johnson.
Boris Johnson wasn't a British prime minister
at the time, so it was a marginally different
group.
And it's the story about how, uh, you know,
the little rocket man stuff got Kim Jong Un
all wound up and he mentions Elton John when
he tells the story.
I mean, it sounds like it would be a Saturday
night live parody of what Trump says to world
leaders, but it's a literal speech that Donald
Trump has now been telling world leaders for
multiple years.
And the world leaders that see Trump up close
are understandably horrified by his behavior.
And that's terrible.
If you care about the image of the United
States around the world, you don't have to
be, you know, a, a hyper nationalist to just
care if the country you live in is perceived
as being headed up by a clueless, a clown.
And a no, no offense to clowns of course.
But, uh, it's a totally respectable job.
Um, but it is something that you can care
about merely because you care about the image
of the country you live in.
Now there's a silver lining here.
Uh, Trump really likes Kim Jong moon and he's
not just saying it.
In other words, Trump lies so often that when
we get what seems to be corroboration about
something, Donald Trump thinks in this case
that he likes Kim Jong Goon.
There's this tiny silver lining in that we
found out, Trump actually told the truth truth
about something.
The trend is that when Trump is being honest,
he often is saying that he likes the dictator.
One of the, one of the things Donald Trump
and his presidency has been most honest about,
one area where we can believe him is when
he's talking about a dictator or an authoritarian
strongman in glowing terms.
That seems to actually be just honest.
Donald Trump, and the problem of course is
that he's so easy to manipulate in North Korea's
Kim family has been trying to control American
presidents for decades, but normally the American
presidents and the people around them have
the diplomatic sense not to allow these propaganda
meetings with no preconditions because they
know they're only good for North Korea.
They're only good for the propaganda that
North Korea will then generate from these
meetings.
And we get nothing.
And much like Trump's been played by the Russians
before, he's getting played by Kim Jong Un
and it's working to such a degree that in
private he's just glowing about just how terrific
Kim Jong own is.
Now on Friday, we are going to deal with the
question when should a president meet versus
not meet or negotiate with different people.
It's an important topic and it relates to
Trump and North Korea.
We can't just criticize Trump.
We need to lay out a framework for when does
dialogue make sense and when his dialogue
or at least dialogue without preconditions,
not the right thing, I will deal with that
on the Friday show in audience questions.